good morning
sajin javid starts work as health
secretary this morning following the
resignation of matt hancock
mr javid's top priority will be beating
the covert 19 pandemic as the number of
cases continues to rise
in his resignation letter mr hancock
apologized again for breaking rules on
social distancing
that he had asked others to follow and
to his family for what he had put them
through
our political editor beth rigby reports
this now the moment when the personal
proved politically fateful for matt
hancock
the health secretary resigning over
pictures of him
breaking his own social distancing
guidance and possibly the law but his
relationship with old friend and
political aid gina colla d'angelo
raising far more than personal scandal
criticism too
over his decision to put her on the
public payroll
collard angelo left her post on the
board at the department of health as mr
hancock realized he too
had to go those of us who make these
rules
have got to stick by them and that's why
i've got to resign i want to thank
people for their incredible sacrifices
and what they've done
everybody working in the nhs across
social care
everyone involved in the in the vaccine
program
and frankly everybody in this country
who has
risen to the challenges that we've seen
over this past
18 months i'm very proud of what we've
done
to protect the nhs at the peak to
deliver that vaccine rollout for one of
the fastest in the world
and i look forward to supporting
the government and the prime minister
from the back benches
to make sure that we can get out of this
pandemic
we're so close to the end are you
hopeless mr hancock i don't think so
is it your chance to give the version of
events today mr hancock mr hancock had
become used to defending himself
in recent weeks embarrassing leaked text
messages from the pm described
him as hopeless former aide dominic
cummings told mps
mr hancock was incompetent a liar unfit
for high
office but then little option but to
hand in his resignation letter to the
prime minister
who in turn said he was sorry to receive
it
but many colleagues thought mr hancock
had no option
it's okay having the support
and the confidence of the prime minister
but in a pandemic you've also got to
have the support and the confidence of
the public
and although i think they had some
sympathy with him over the affair
it wasn't that it was the perceived
hypocrisy
of telling people to do one thing and
doing another yourself
the labour leader also glad he's gone
but thinks the pm should have pushed him
i think this reveals the weakness lack
of judgment
lack of leadership from boris johnson
that he didn't sack him
and if number 10 our briefing this was
matt hancock's decision not boris
johnson
i think that tells you even more so that
boris johnson
isn't cut out for the demands of
leadership
but with the vaccine rollout still
underway he does
need an experienced leader in such a
demanding department
appointing former chancellor sajid javid
as the new health secretary
the pair last worked together before the
pandemic hit
mr javid return into the cabinet in very
different circumstances
one old friend and political ally
confident
he said he just taken the appointment
from the prime minister but he knows how
to
run organizations he's run businesses
he's been
secretary of state in a number of
departments as well as being the
former chancellor i think that he'll
give
the nhs an important focus is a huge
organization a huge
employee he has compassion he believes
in public
service he believes in the public sector
um i i think this is a very good
an inspired appointment from the prime
minister
this government and its former health
secretary will have
many questions to answer when that
inquiry begins
but for now the man that has led on
public health
for 15 months brought down not by his
political record
but his personal life beth rigby sky
news
well sajid javid has a huge task ahead
of him
helping the nhs through the pandemic the
overwhelming focus on the coronavirus
means that more than 5 million
people are now on waiting lists as i
have been at airport
on the embankment wall facing parliament
there is a heart for every single
coronavirus victim in britain
and for those who have a loved one
represented here this scandal
has been particularly hard to fathom
fran hall is part of the covid19 beread
families for justice group
she lost her husband steve in the
pandemic last year
the country as a whole we've done what
we've been asked to do
so to find out that it doesn't apply
this rule of keeping your distance and
not interacting with other households
two people in charge it's just it's so
disappointing
and it's so worrying as well because all
moral authority has gone
regaining that moral authority will
clearly not be easy though
that much evident at an anti-lockdown
protest in central london just hours
before matt hancock's resignation
but sadid javid faces several other
challenges too
15 months into the pandemic nhs staff
are at breaking point
not just from their physical toil but at
what they see as a lack of recognition
unions are still demanding the
government increase its recommended 1
pay rise to prevent staff leaving
then there's the backlog of patients
more than 5 million on the formal
waiting list for treatment
and an estimated seven million more who
have stayed away from hospital during
the pandemic
the pressures are unprecedented so his
first task really
is to restore some calm he needs to
give the reassurance that he's fully
informed
uh about the position we're in he knows
the science he knows where we are
and that he needs to ensure that he asks
for trust and that he's going to offer
that back
to the public even for an experienced
pair of ministerial hands it is not an
easy task
the government's locked down mantra of
togetherness in danger
of falling apart iva bennett sky news
well the resignation of matt hancock
after he admitted
breaking the coronavirus restrictions on
the front pages of all the papers and
obviously we're going to be covering it
all day here um joining me now is peter
cardwell he's a former special adviser
in both boris johnson and theresa may's
um governments
peter thank you so much for joining us
so we finally reached the threshold for
ministerial resignation in this
government
yes i think it was right that matt
hancock resigned
he made that decision and i think it was
right that he went
obviously he made a huge mistake there's
a breach of trust there
in terms of him breaking those social
distancing regulations i don't think
people are too concerned necessarily
with who he was doing it with although
obviously that is
desperately sad for both him and his
family
and those affected you say it's right
that he's gone but do you think
the amount of time that it took was
right we saw him
come out apologize say yes i've broken
the guidelines we saw the pm say um the
mat is closed
and then what 36 48 hours later he
resigns shouldn't he have just done it
straight away i think sometimes in
politics it takes a little while for
things to set in
of course the public reaction wasn't
really known but
it was inevitable that this was going to
happen
i think it's very sad that it has
happened i think
despite huge uh challenges and i'm not
going to say for a second that he did
everything right as health secretary of
course
mistakes were made but he certainly was
someone who
i've known for 11 years he had a very
stellar
ministerial career and that position of
health secretary
was not an easy one at any stage but
certainly not one that pandemic hit
i think in terms of the timing of his
resignation there are questions to be
asked about whether boris johnson should
have
sacked him previously but of course as
time went on it became untenable it
became very very clear
that he had to resign what do you make
of
labour's calls this morning last night
that he should have been sacked
well i think you can look over the last
48 hours 36 48 hours and say things
should have happened at certain times
the fact is matt hancock has resigned um
i think labor have failed at various
points to provide an alternative to this
government
i think they are weak and i think that
they're attacking the government
when it is in trouble and that's
perfectly fine that's what an opposition
should be doing but the fact is that the
chronology of this isn't going to
concern the public too much
i think the fact that hancock is gone is
what people will know and that they will
realize that sachit javid
is now the new health secretary and he
has a huge job
ahead of him on a job i think he'll do
very very well he's someone who's very
experienced
within government of course he's been
the chancellor he's been the home
secretary he's been the housing
secretary he's been the culture
secretary
and from day one he may not know every
single thing about the health service
but of course he will know the mechanics
of government he knows how to lead
and he knows that there is a huge job to
be done in a pandemic and i think
perhaps some of the reluctance of boris
johnson to sacrament hancock
was perhaps to do with the fact that
that job is so big
it's probably the most important job in
the cabinet at the moment
and such a java is the right man for the
job
we'll get to javid in a moment but you
say that the the public will know
that matt hancock resigned they'll also
know that boris johnson didn't sack him
does that mean that boris johnson
doesn't think it's serious enough that
he broke those guidelines
i think it's a bit strange that boris
johnson said you know this
is not over essentially we've seen
previously
that neil ferguson for example from sage
we've seen the deputy chief medical
officer of scotland those two had
apparently
broken uh lockdown restrictions had
broken the
guidance that certainly they were
involved in setting and both of them
went so it
i think it would have been pretty clear
that mal hancock's position was
untenable
the prime minister for whatever reason
decided not to stock matt hancock and of
course
but hancock fell in the sword but as i
said the chronology of all of this
i think won't be remembered necessarily
um the prime minister of course
was probably reluctant to have sacked
his health secretary during this
pandemic wanting a bit of continuity of
leadership
during such a difficult time for the
public and
in terms of public health but i think it
became inevitable
matt hancock did the right thing okay
sergey javid um
he's been brought in you say he's the
best man for the job but
he had a huge row with boris johnson 16
months ago
so huge in fact that he resigned as
chancellor four weeks before the budget
yes that's right and that was a pretty
unedifying affair the involvement of
course of dominic cummings cannot be
forgotten in all of that dominic
cummings was insistent
that mr uh javid's whole team his team
of special advisers people do the job
that i did
were to be sacked and of course mr java
decided to be loyal to his special
advisers and decided to
uh to go which was an absolutely
dramatic thing to happen which involved
rishi sunak becoming
the chancellor and of course i think
there's a bit of unfinished business
there i think mr
johnson probably feels a bit guilty
about that affair
as such a javid probably shouldn't have
gone at that point although rishi soon
after the night standing chancellor
and i think that there is perhaps
because of that unfinished business he
feels that such a jabba
should come back of course what all
could have happened i suppose is that
mr johnson could have promoted someone
from within another minister
but then he created a sort of domino
effect that one rule has to be filled in
has to be filled it has to be filled in
so bringing back a back venture and
someone who has actually been very loyal
to this government
uh despite the fact he was treated
pretty shabbily is
now the health secretary and that is
someone who can hit the ground running
such at javid
tomorrow morning he'll be in the
department of health and he'll be making
all the decisions that affect our lives
and will hopefully
get us our freedoms back on the 19th of
july
okay peter thank you so much for talking
to us
well also this morning 156 people are
still missing after an apartment block
collapsed in florida one body has been
found overnight and it's now been
revealed that three years ago
engineers warned about serious faults in
the construction of the building
martha kelner reports from florida
acrid smoke hangs heavy in the air
across surf side
a constant reminder of the tragedy still
unfolding here
fires burned deep in the wreckage still
smoldering despite the storm judy
spiegel was in the building
her husband kevin who was away on
business knows this unthinkable
purgatory
won't be over anytime soon i do cry
on and off you know and you know try to
comfort the kids
and the grandkids um is really my focus
your grandkids know or well yeah we told
scarlett
that grandma's lost and we can't find
her
and you know she she knows something's
up she doesn't know why
but grandma was always there to take
care of her and that she's not there
she's very concerned every day here
brings fresh heartbreak
for the families of the five dead and
156 people
still missing this time it was news of a
report
which found major structural damage in
the vicinity of the building
and crumbling of columns in the parking
garage beneath
that was three years ago when the
building came down in the early hours of
thursday morning
repairs still hadn't started the
champlain towers north is almost
identical to the champlain towers south
which collapsed
it was built at the same time with the
same design
yet residents here still haven't been
evacuated
they want reassurances from florida's
governor
that they're not in danger too would you
feel safe going to sleep tonight if
you're in the sister building of this
just 100 yards away
i know they are considering potentially
evacuating them
uh but that's something that uh you know
ultimately the mayor is going to have to
make the call on
you for all your all your fights yeah
yeah yeah
understand um
few dollars here william has moved out
of his own accord with all his
belongings in one plastic bag
i'm very very worried i am 75 years old
in my
living every day every day with the
strength of the building could be
collapsed
the apartment block was built on
reclaimed wetlands
like many in this area a study had found
it was sinking into the ground
at a rate of two millimeters a year in
the
1990s what we we found was that the the
land was subsiding was
lowering down in several places
when we see only one building that is
moving
uh we cannot say exactly why so with the
champlain towers south it was very
localized it was just that building that
was subsiding at that point
that's right
it could be months perhaps even years
before families discover
what exactly caused the building to
collapse devastating lives and changing
this beach town forever
now authorities are under pressure to
ensure it can never happen again
martha kellner sky news florida
official figures suggest that by the end
of today half of all under 30s will have
received their first dose of a
coronavirus vaccine let's speak to our
correspondent shaman freeman powell
morning shaman so
young people continuing to take up the
offer of a vaccine
yes they have been and the government
are describing this as a real
milestone moment it now means that more
than
60 percent of adults in the uk have had
their first
vaccine um sorry more than four and five
adults in the uk have their first
vaccine with more than 60
now having had both doses and the nhs
are also really pleased with this
turnout as well they say that it proves
that young people
do understand the importance of being
protected against the virus and said
that it's been particularly good
in those areas of low take-up i've
actually been traveling around some of
these centers in london
and have come across people that were at
first hesitant about getting their
vaccine
however i had seen these walk-in centres
and decided to go along
and take it up so the government are
hoping that this continues
and that more of those over the age of
18 will continue to use these centers
today
ahead of that crucial july the 19th date
which
most of the restrictions will be lifted
and so more people will be protected
with these vaccinations
sherman thank you right time for the
weather now here's nice
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking pretty wet to
say the least across southern areas of
the uk
for today tonight tomorrow even into the
day after but elsewhere it's looking
mostly fine thanks to high pressure
we're going to see
largely dry and sunny conditions into
this afternoon quite a cloudy start
around northern and eastern part so with
some drizzle and
cloudy across the south where we are
seeing spells of rain already across
many
central southwestern areas in particular
but also some showery rain towards the
southeast
the rain will continue across these
areas into this afternoon there will be
some
heavy downpours likely at times
especially down towards southwestern
areas but later towards the southeast as
well
and it may spread up a little further
northwards towards southern parts of
wales central england towards
areas of suffolk as well elsewhere
though there will be bright or sunny
spells developing it will be a mainly
dry
afternoon and it will feel pleasantly
warm in any sunshine particularly across
northwestern parts although for the
northwest of scotland
there is a weak front there bringing
cloudy skies some patchy light rain and
drizzle too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
sergey javid starts work today as health
secretary he replaces matt hancock who
resigned last night after admitting
breaking coronavirus rules let's speak
to our political correspondent
who joins us from westminster good
morning rob so sadja javed back in
cabinets
but this time around with possibly the
most difficult job
in government yeah exactly kimberly and
i think given that context and the scale
of the task
in that department it perhaps wasn't a
surprise
that boris johnson reached for someone
like sajid javid
to fill that space someone that has got
extensive cabinet
experience but crucially someone as well
who's not in the cabinet
at the moment and so there would be no
need for a wider reshuffle
of his top team as you say a daunting
task ahead i think even without the
pandemic there's a raft of nhs reforms
on the table as well as that long
promised social care reform
that boris johnson has spoken about for
the last two years but as yet
has not delivered though i think the
most immediate
uh thing on his entry though and the
most immediate decisions he will have to
play a part in
is around the coronavirus restrictions
july the 19th
is still the day where the country is
due to have all legal restrictions
um lifted sajid javid during his time on
the back benches was someone that didn't
vote against the government
on covid lockdowns and restrictions he's
someone that said that he thinks they
got the balance
about right between protecting public
health and protecting the economy
but it should be said on paper he does
come from
a sort of more libertarian viewpoint in
politics than matt hancock did
and on that i mean that he may well have
more appreciation if you like of the
rights of the individual
and also you're talking about a former
chancellor someone that has worked in
business in private enterprise as well
who is also
close and friends with the current
chancellor rishi sunak so whether that
tips the balance within cabinet
from a position uh to a more a more
skeptical position
on restrictions when those arguments
rear their head again potentially in the
winter
will be interesting to see it well rob
thank you so much
well the beginning of the end for matt
hancock came with the publication of his
embrace with gina collidangelo by the
sun newspaper on
friday joining me now is the political
editor of the sun on sunday
david wooding david good morning to you
thanks a lot for talking to us
just having a look at your front page
this morning it's it's interesting isn't
it what do you make of the fact that
despite all the ppe shortage issues the
care home issues it was this
that cut through yes people are prepared
to take
ministers making mistakes we all make
mistakes
what they're not happy to put up with is
hypocrisy
and uh matt hancock was telling the rest
of us dictating to us
how we lived our lives during this
pandemic some felt he was overzealous
even within
the ranks of his own government some
ministers felt he was
a little bit over the top in the
restrictions he wanted to impose he was
regarded as you know one of the hawks of
uh of lockdown
uh and then to be found breaking the
rules himself
no matter how small the rule break uh is
uh he just had to go did you think going
into this on friday that
we would be here on sunday and he would
have already quit by now
well he was determined to brazen it out
and we were told uh
as late as yesterday morning when i rang
number 10 i was convinced he would have
been gone by the weekend
uh because the pressure was mounting
number 10
said no he's not going there's nothing
here it's all
it's all finished we're not discussing
it any further um
i i was still convinced he would have
gone by the end of yesterday
and then there was massive silence from
uh from
ben pease nobody was uh rowing in to
defend him
uh if any in any rank whatsoever and
then suddenly
we got radio silence from from all
quarters and
and i i just knew it was going to happen
and then the announcement came
did you think he was going to be sacked
or do you think he was going to resign
well this is another issue people are
discussing because of boris johnson's
own
rather colorful private life there is a
feeling in westminster that he is loath
to sac people i don't think it's quite
as simple as that
i think boris johnson himself doesn't
like uh dispensing with people's
services
uh and he does find it hard to to remove
people who aren't uh doing their job
properly i'm afraid
uh however in this instance it was matt
hancock who
who saw the writing on the wall and
decided it was time to fall on his sword
and rightly so too
do you think that the reaction on friday
just reinforced that narrative of
them and us yes uh that has been
an issue throughout uh a number of
issues
where uh we've always said is it one
rule for you
and one rule for everybody else i mean
even the scientists remember
professor lockdown as we called him who
who was one of the most
zealous of the scientists telling us how
we had to live our lives
and he was um doing something similar to
matt hancock and it
then became irresistible for everybody
to pile in on matt hancock because
he too was uh was breaking the rules you
you can't preach to us
how we live our lives and don't forget
people have
have not been able to pay their respects
properly to loved ones at funerals their
weddings have been restricted
even myself i wasn't able to see my own
two two children who were grown up over
christmas last year
and i think people felt rather bitter to
see the the video footage
of matt hancock living his life
differently from the rest of us
more broadly david what do you think it
says about the state of play of the
government that you've got people
leaking cctv images like this
well this has happened from time to
memorial i don't think it's anything to
do with this government in particular
we have whistleblowers thankfully in
life now i know
the laws have been changed to try and
make it increasingly difficult
to people to uh to speak out when
something goes wrong in public service
but it's right that they do
because these people are elected by us
to
protect our lives protect our country
and look after us and tell us
how we live our lives and it's only
right that when they uh
fall short that they should be exposed
and
and more power to the whistleblowers i
say okay david thank you so much for
talking to us
now the theft of a dog can be
devastating under current laws
pets are considered property so if
they're stolen it's considered the same
as the theft of a bike or a tv
but now there are calls for much tougher
sentences as milena vasilinovich reports
for seven years gerald mccarthy's dog
molly helped him cope with the sudden
death of his wife but in february molly
was snatched from his garden in broad
daylight
and gerald says that losing her
companionship was a huge blow
she was part of my life big part of my
life massive part of my life
you know the first thing when i finished
work every day was just
you know you wanted to get on for molly
and um my day old
all my all my days were just revolved
around you know looking after molly and
that's what they are they're part of
your life
bit like family yeah i hope absolutely
absolutely well she was my little girl
but legally
pets are classed as property so when
they're taken
it's no different to a stolen bike and
for katie stickley whose dog
trigger was returned by the police eight
months after he was stolen
this doesn't reflect the emotional bond
between pets
and their owners it should be classed as
kidnapped because it's a living person
even though it's not a human it's still
living
and it's still part of the family i felt
sick like that someone's actually done
that
um felt
like shaky and helpless that you can't
do nothing like it was like if one of
your children was to get stolen
on monday parliament will debate
proposals that could make it easier for
stolen pets to be reunited with their
rightful owners
like making microchip scanning
compulsory for vets
but many want the government to go
further and a petition to make dog theft
a specific offence with a minimum two
year sentence
has got more than half a million
signatures
the current legislation isn't tough
enough uh people can
steal a pet and they might get a fine
maybe a 120 pounds something like that
rather than you know face the full force
of the law
and that's because it doesn't take into
consideration you know the traumatic
effect it has on the family so
what we want to do is have the law
recognize the trauma
that's causing a family by having a pet
stolen and an appropriate sentence in
that situation
gerald now has a new dog but says that
nothing can replace molly
he and many others want robust
punishment for those
who steal beloved pets milana
masalinovic sky news
time for the weather it's nice
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning rather wet one for the next
couple of days across southern parts of
the uk
there'll be rain on and off and some
heavy downpours at times as well
elsewhere though looking fine lots of
sunshine expected into this afternoon
bit of a cloudy start this morning
around northern and east and parts where
there's some drizzle but
it is brighter further west and we'll
see skies brighten up for many areas
into this afternoon north sea
facing coastal areas and may stay quite
cool and cloudy for much of the day and
it stays cloudy across
many southern counties of england as
well particularly for central south
western parts
where there will be spells of rain this
morning continuing into this afternoon
and then returning in towards
southeastern areas where you can see
some rather intense downpours unlikely
and they may spread up to
southern parts of wales central england
towards suffolk as well
norfolk perhaps just about getting away
with some sunshine there
and in fact it looks fine and sunny
elsewhere across the uk island for this
afternoon
mainly dry feeling warm particularly
across northwestern areas
where the highest temperatures likely
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello again time for another look at the
papers and with us this morning to take
us through nikki hodgson
and marianne a hotter nikki marianne
thanks a lot
um for joining us this morning obviously
matt hancock
on the front of all of the pages with
his resignation um mary ann you've
chosen the times
for us to um go through what's their
take on it
so left hand side it's all about end of
marriage
having to resign focus on instead
on the columns on the right hand side
this story about the private email
account that had covered business from
officials now those of us who've been
around the sun quite a few times
may well have wondered well hang on a
minute if those photos that
you know would probably prompt hancock's
resignation
if they were taken in may why is it
taken until the end of june for them to
be
uh published um and
the question is what are we trying to
perhaps deflect attention from
what is the me what is the kind of the
reason for for the timing
now and one of the answers may well be
that there's an awful lot of um other
kinds of speculation
going on at the moment and accusations
and a growing body of evidence that
shows that
perhaps these kind of questions about
you know
dodgy dealings with the ppe contracts
certain contractors who have no
background in supplying uh
pharmaceuticals or protective equipment
to the nhs suddenly getting
multi multi-million pound contracts um
you know there's this kind of these
these these middle
men operators who got massive backhands
on the basis of kind of commission
basically on the basis of securing these
deals and they just so happen to you
know be pals with ministers or have very
um uh significant connections and this
uh particular story is about some
um minutes of a meeting that was held
between senior officials at the
department of health and social care
uh that's been leaked to the times
saying that um civil servants basically
know that matt hancock was operating a
private personal account which he used
as a means of communicating not only
with members of his office but also
other contractors and other cabinet
members to
discuss amongst other things things like
ppe contracts as well as
other aspects of not only covid pandemic
but other
other elements of his of his official
business
now this breaches the rules of the ways
that ministers ought to
to kind of operate their their working
business it should all be through
government accounts because then
there's a clear record of it there's
scrutiny uh it's not necessarily all
going to be released to the public but
there's scrutin
scrutiny within the kind of the
mechanisms of power
and matt hancock hasn't been doing that
at least since march 2020
and this meeting was held in december
2020
and this weekend also the the good lord
project
we're gonna have to leave it there
marianne because we're gonna run out
we're running out of time we need to
move on
sorry anyone's alright question yeah
questions and
really need answering so uh let's not
take our eye off the ball because this
is the real story i think
yeah we'll see how that develops um
sticking with
the covert theme and the leaked email
theme um
nikki the express page six and seven
a cancer avalanche what's this about
yeah so this was always something that
was going to be uh it was well it was
predicted by many a medic
at the beginning of the pandemic that as
a result of the restrictions in terms of
treatment the
the overflow of beds needed for covered
patients
those that had cancer were not going to
receive treatment on time
and this is saying that uh this is again
this is from a leaked email again from a
london hospital
and it's saying that a record 230 000
patients have been sent for checks
um since march this year and that's
as a direct result of the pandemic and
so as we say
this was predicted long ago by medics
the nhs was completely overwhelmed
anyway and it was going to be
overwhelmed so
you know it's been a terrible year to be
in the medical profession
but uh what the advisors in this piece
make very clear is that
it's important to say that uh if the
politicians say that the nhs
is coping very well if boris johnson now
says oh we're doing very well because
you know
we've got more beds back and uh look how
brilliantly everything is going
but that's effectively a lie and um
professor carol
uh socorro who was quoted in this piece
actually says it is dishonest to say
that the nhs is coping very well
at the moment because of so many of
these cancer patients many of whom are
in their 20s and 30s
okay that's also interesting going to
see how um that pans out
the pressure on the nhs you wouldn't
want to be the health secretary would
you
um marianne um the telegraph page
two this is interesting because we're
always told that we're all gonna have to
be vegetarian if we want to hit the
climate um
targets aren't we well yeah this is
i mean this is a conversation that we're
all going to have
um a lot over the next few years i think
the uk have a legally mandated target of
achieving net zero carbon missions by
2050
and some of the kind of the easy games
have been made things like
um increasing renewable energy so you
know all those offshore wind farms
things like that
replacing some of the the coal-fired
power stations
but in the next 10 years or so and and
then going forwards
a lot of the changes that we're going to
have to make
in terms of tackling climate change
keeping global net warming to below 1.5
degrees centigrade
is going to be about consumer choices
that's not just what car you're going to
drive
what transport you choose to make it's
also going to be things like what we eat
and george eustis the environment
secretary has come out
saying well you know we've got
government advisors saying that we're
all going to have to cut our meat
by about one-fifth that's not loads
let's be honest it's not all becoming
you know vegan or anything like that
we're gonna have to cut our meat by
about one-fifth meat consumption and
choose higher value higher welfare
possibly a little bit more expensive
but it's okay because you're eating less
so overall
it might be cost neutral for most people
um
and george eastern is saying well hang
on a minute we don't want to
lecture to people because that puts them
off the thing is though
we're all in this together and the
implications of us
not doing enough are catastrophic
for our future generations so it's not
so much that we can all blindly carry on
you know eating our cheap burgers and
and um
you know stocking up the barbecue
with no consequences there are very real
consequences it's your house getting
flooded it's there's wildfires
it's um a lack of of kind of food
for for millions of people elsewhere in
in the world
um and the kind of the big question is
how do we actually tackle this
responsibly
and help people all of us make
positive decisions that are good for the
climate also good for our bodies and our
health
in a way that the government can support
and it sort of comes off the back of
you know the government are kind of
touting around the world looking for
free trade deals to compensate for for
for brexit